-Oh, man.
-Hey!
-I'm so happy you're here,
and I loved singing with you.
Man, oh, man.
We've been --
We've been doing this for a
while now, me and you singing.
-We make a great team.
-We really do, bud.
Is it true that your dream
was to be a backup singer?
-Yes, and that died.
Yeah, that -- Yeah.
[ Both laugh ]
-That was my dream.
'Cause I thought
it'd be so cool.
I love so many types of artists
and all different genres,
so I thought it'd be cool to get
to travel with different artists
and go all over the world and
sing different genres of music.
So that didn't work out.
-No. Did you ever sing backup
when you were starting out?
-No, I sang -- I mean, I sang
with people all the time, like,
growing up, like, sang in
different groups and stuff,
but as far like
being paid professionally, no,
I just did, like, demo work.
I was, like, a demo singer.
-I would freak out
if I saw you as a back--
I'm, like --
What? Who's that?
-I loved it, though.
So, Reba McEntire and I
actually did a tour together,
and it was fun,
because we switched, and every
time one would do their song,
we'd sing backup for them
on the song.
Like, she would sing
my pop-rock stuff,
and I would sing her stuff,
and we'd be background singers,
basically, for those songs.
It was so fun.
-With Reba?
-Yeah.
-That's legendary.
-Well, you sing all kinds
of songs on your show
in your Kellyoke segment,
which has blown up.
It is the biggest thing.
I mean, I love that, because I
remember talking to you
right before you were starting
the show, and you're like,
"Yeah, I have a great band,
I might sing,
I might do a thing," and you had
it all planned out, and I go,
"All right, man," and, dude,
you really did it.
And you're crushing it.
I mean, it's --
-Well, I think ignorance
is bliss, Jimmy.
I had no idea
what the hell I was doing.
So, like, everybody was like,
"You should do a show,"
and I was like, "Okay."
Like, I didn't have a plan,
so I thought,
"Well, we should incorporate
music, obviously."
-But then,
you won an Emmy for it.
-I did!
-Congratulations.
-Oh, my gosh.
You have to hear
how I found out I won.
So, everything's weird now,
like awards shows.
Everything's different now.
So you it's not, like, normal,
and usually you're there.
So I have had a really different
kind of couple of months
than what maybe I was expecting
my future to look like
a few months ago.
And so, I'm with my kids, and
I'm really present with them,
I'm kind of single-momming it
now, so I'm like, you know,
with Legos, I'm coloring,
I never have my phone on,
never watch TV.
Totally forgot that the Emmys
were -- just totally --
I blanked 'cause I'm just so
hyper-focused,
and there's a lot
going on in my life.
And so, it's kind of been
a rough month for me
at that point,
and my executive producer
just calls me and like,
out of nowhere for me,
I'm just sitting there
playing Legos, and she was like,
"You're the best host."
And I was like --
And I almost started crying.
I was like, "Thank you so much."
I was like --
-"You are so sweet!"
-"You're so nice!"
I was like, "You're so --
This is a kind thing
to do, Alex,
to just call someone and tell
them they're good at something.
I needed that."
And she was like, "No, you won,
at the Emmys,"
and I was like, "What?!"
And then my kids were like,
"You won!"
They were, like, sitting there,
and they were so excited.
They had no idea
why they're excited,
but they were freaking out.
Yeah, that was how I found out.
-That's so cool.
What do you think now?
You're back in the studio,
right?
-Yes.
-Which is --
How's it like for you?
I know it's --
You're coming back
September 21st.
Does it feel odd to you,
going back in the studio?
Is it safe?
Obviously, it's safe, but...
-I don't know --
Yes, oh, my gosh.
I am the safest person around.
'Cause, like, "The Voice," like,
other jobs, this job --
I have to take a test for all
of them, so I take, like --
Carson Daly and I -- we take
like eight tests a week.
-Yeah.
-We are very, very safe,
and the all guidelines --
you get it.
It's very different.
But I don't know how you feel,
but I, because my show actually
ran throughout the summer
because we were trying
to finish out my first season.
And it's been running
this whole time, honestly.
And I adapt
pretty easily in life,
so I didn't really --
Like, everybody was like,
"Oh, is it weird singing?
There's no people there,"
and I was like,
"Well, no, 'cause I sing in
a studio all the time anyway."
And then they're like,
"Oh, is it weird interviewing?"
And I was like, "Well, it really
was just my first time
doing this anyways, so I didn't
really know what the norm was."
So I was just kind of like,
"Yeah, however we're gonna
do it, let's do it."
So it hasn't really bothered me
either way,
and being back in the studio,
it's kind of cool
'cause we have
a virtual audience,
and they're from all over
the world, and so --
and they're all there, like,
in the audience seats.
And we have guests, like,
there in person
and also still coming virtually,
and we kind of sit the screen
next to me.
So it's interesting,
and it's definitely
technical-difficulty hell
sometimes,
but it's worth it, though.
It's worth it.
-Yeah. So, the audience is there
so you can actually see
people in the audience --
-Yeah.
-I play off of my audience, and
they're from, like, everywhere.
That's kind of the cool thing
is our whole show
is about connections.
So the cool thing is,
we really are connecting,
like, all over the globe.
-That is unbelievable.
And are they doing the same
thing on "The Voice"?
I know you're coming back.
-Yeah, they're doing it
on "The Voice," too.
It's not as -- It can't be
as interactive on "The Voice"
just because of all
the elements in play.
It's a little more interactive
on the TV show,
but on "The Voice," they do.
They have a huge thing
in the screen,
and we can interact with them.
It's just a little --
You know, it's more about
the artist, obviously, there,
and it's more of, like,
they're just watching,
and we chime in
every now and then with them.
But it's interesting, though,
because even doing "The Voice,"
you hear everything.
It's far more intimate.
It's really different,
and it's kind of cool.
All the coaches are kinda like,
"This is cool."
-You can hear everyone's --
actually hear their voice.
-No, well, I just mean,
you can hear --
Like, the crowd goes wild
on certain parts,
and you're like, "Wait!
We can't hear everything."
-Yeah.
-And then my mom will call me
and be like, "Why did you say
they did good?
They were so off-key."
And I was --
-I love mom.
I love mom so much.
Come on. What would you do
without your mom?
Well, congrats on "The Voice"
in October,
you have your show coming back
September 21st.
Pal, you're one of my faves.
Thank you so much
for doing the show.
I appreciate it.
We always have fun together,
so thank you for doing that.